[Música]
exactamente una semana atrás estaba con
mi equipo de la rebelión del cuerpo un
colectivo social que tenemos en chile y
está ya en 6 países del mundo también
estábamos marchando en el día de
conmemoración de la no violencia contra
la mujer en la mitad de la marcha se me
acercó una niña de alrededor de 16 años
y me dice tú eres la de la región del
cuerpo y yo le digo sí soy yo y me dice
tengo algo que decirte me dice no te
imaginas la cantidad de años que llevo
sufriendo por cómo me siento respecto a
mí misma la cantidad de años porque he
sufrido y me he sentido víctima de todas
las exigencias que me han puesto
respecto a mi cuerpo la cantidad de
hospitalizaciones que he tenido por una
anorexia que me ha tenido atrapada por
muchos años pero el día que yo vi en su
página y en sus redes sociales una
historia de otra mujer que había vivido
exactamente lo mismo que yo por primera
vez me sentí acompañada por primera vez
dejé de sentirme sola en mi sufrimiento
fue interpelado emocionante cada vez que
me pasa me emociona mucho le da sentido
a mi cansancio le da sentido al agote le
da sentido a las miles de veces que ha
dicho no quiero tanta responsabilidad no
puedo más con todo esto es muy grande y
sigue creciendo y no sé cómo hacerlo es
interesante darte cuenta de que tiene
mucho sentido y que cada vez que uno va
caminando y una mamá te dice tú eres la
de la reunión del cuerpo y te abraza y
te da las gracias por todo lo que tú has
hecho por su hija cuando no tienes idea
quién es su hija o un hombre que se
acerca y te dice por primera vez
entiendo lo que las mujeres sufren nunca
me lo habían explicado como ustedes lo
muestran todos los días o profesoras y
profesores que también nos dicen gracias
por darle el peso que tiene nuestra
labor en la construcción de identidad de
las niñas y los niños y es interesante
pensar que de esta forma en un año y
medio hemos logrado entrar al
inconsciente colectivo de muchas mujeres
no sólo de chile sino de todos los otros
países en los que estamos y también de
todas las seguidoras que muchas veces
nos comentan de diferentes partes del
mundo
es interesante también darse cuenta que
el propósito de esto hemos recibido
muchas invitaciones de distintos
organismos públicos y privados para que
vayamos a hablar no sólo de cómo hemos
logrado movilizar a tantas mujeres o
como hemos logrado despertar y abrirle
los ojos a una sociedad sino también
cómo hemos pasado de lo privado a lo
público como algo que hemos logrado en
algún momento sacar la voz a tal punto
de que muchos partidos nos están
llamando para decir a ver cuéntenos qué
es esto de la violencia simbólica qué es
esto del impacto que tienen los medios
de comunicación la publicidad y las
redes sociales es la seguridad de
nuestras niñas explíquenos de qué se
trata y veamos de qué forma también
podemos empezar a legislar en esto en
este momento y a propósito de estas
mismas invitaciones hace un par de
semanas atrás recibimos una invitación
organizada para un conversatorio
organizada por diferentes partidos
políticos lo interesante fue que la
invitación explícita y concreta era que
fuéramos a contar la estrategia y la
metodología que habíamos usado todo este
año y medio para hacer crecer este
colectivo principalmente para que
fuéramos a explicar cómo
hemos movilizado a tantas mujeres como
las habíamos despertado a no sentir un
rechazo cuando hablamos de este tema
sino sentirse parte de iu a la vez
también como habíamos logrado como
logramos cotidianamente hacer noticia en
cada denuncia de publicidad sexista que
aparece por lo menos en nuestro país y
de esta desde esta lógica a la vez
también una de las cosas que más nos
pedían que les hiciéramos entender era
cómo habíamos logrado instalar un
espacio democrático entre mujeres donde
por primera vez pudiesen decir
públicamente no estoy de acuerdo no
quiero que esto siga pasando yo voto por
que esta campaña deje de existir y así
con la voz de todas las mujeres que se
han sentido parte de esto hemos logrado
bajar más de cinco campañas gigantes a
nivel de chile y otras a nivel de
latinoamérica también
el tema fue que en el momento en el que
nos sentamos como equipo a pensar en
cómo habíamos logrado esto en cuál era
esa metodología o esa estrategia por la
que nos estaban preguntando nos dimos
cuenta de que no teníamos la menor idea
estábamos súper claras en que habíamos
logrado lo que logramos y lo que estamos
logrando pero no sabíamos cómo no
existía una metodología había sido muy
de huata como se dicen chile muy
orgánico no sabíamos cuál era nuestra
estrategia entonces tuve que apelar a lo
que siempre apeló cuando necesito pensar
profundamente que es un vodka
me dice en mi web que tónica me fui a
sentar a la terraza aprendí las
lucecitas que me dan como inspiración y
luz divina pongo música agarro mi
cuaderno y anotó absolutamente todo
mientras tomo el busto todo lo que pasa
por mi cabeza cuando necesito encontrar
razones situaciones y explicaciones y lo
que generalmente al otro día cuando leo
mis apuntes veo la luz siempre hay algo
que me sirve entonces me senté en la
terraza y empecé a darle una vuelta a
que fue lo primero que pasó qué fue lo
que pasó que empezó a generar que todo
esto sucediera qué fue lo que pasó que
de un momento a otro teníamos más de mil
seguidores al día teníamos más de 100
comentarios diarios en cada todos que
teníamos todos los días recibíamos
testimonios de diferentes mujeres todos
los días nos mandaban las historias y su
experiencia respecto a su cuerpo a sus
inseguridades a sus dolores a su
sufrimiento a sus abusos a sus
agresiones ya todo lo que vivían
cotidianamente sean las mujeres
no sabíamos que lo que había pasado sin
embargo una de las cosas que más me
interesó fue entender que en el momento
en el que nos etiqueta van en sus
publicaciones en el momento en que
subían una foto del cuerpo que toda la
vida habían escondido porque toda la
vida los habían convencido de que tenían
que esconderlo algo pasado a la
etiquetarnos y darse cuenta de que no
eran las únicas dejaban de sentirse
solas por primera vez su dolor y más
allá de dejar de sentirse sola se
sentían orgullosas de su dolor empezaban
a validarlo y empezaban a darse cuenta
de que ese dolor y es el sufrimiento que
por años nos han dicho que tenemos que
esconder que por años nos han enseñado a
privatizar si lo hacemos público
ayudamos a muchas por primera vez ellas
se empezaron a sentir fuertes respecto a
su vulnerabilidad respecto a sus
inseguridades y el llamado que hacían
cada vez que no se etiquetaban y cada
vez que subieron su foto con el fin de
estar impactando otras mujeres era
hermana compañera o amiga yo siento lo
mismo que tú sientes
estamos solas somos muchas las que
sentimos lo que tú estás sintiendo ven
dame la mano y vamos a luchar juntas
para que ni una niña nunca más tenga que
vivir lo que nosotras estamos viviendo
prioridad pura magnífica que a mí cada
vez que lo pienso digo es lejos lo más
hermoso que puede pasar entre mujeres el
momento en que logramos entender que
somos compañeras y no competencia es
cuando todos los cambios sociales
empiezan a suceder y así fue de cierta
forma el que empezamos a darnos cuenta
de esto y el vodka hizo lo que tenía que
hacer sinapsis
[Música]
pensando este dije ah ya sé lo que pasó
éste es precisamente el inicio de la
rebelión esta es la estrategia y la
metodología por la que me preguntaron y
hoy me di cuenta de que la primera vez
que yo hablé públicamente de la rebelión
del cuerpo fue la primera vez en mi vida
que yo hablaba de mis ocho años de
bulimia
y fue muy fuerte entender que lo que
para mí fue mi rebelión personal que fue
hacer público algo que toda la vida me
había hecho sentir avergonzada algo que
todavía no habían dicho que tenía que
ser escondido al hacerlo público yo
partí a mi rebelión y sin darme cuenta
mi testimonio empezó a abrir la puerta
para los testimonios de muchas otras
mujeres y eso fue hermoso y ahí
y ahí empecé a entender que siempre
sentí vergüenza de lo que me pasó lo
escondía porque sentía vergüenza porque
me habían educado para sentir vergüenza
porque es precisamente la forma en la
que nos educan nos educan para
privatizar el dolor nos educan para
privatizar el sufrimiento nos educan
para sentirnos inseguras de nosotras
mismas y así todo se todo funciona
perfecto porque si yo le quito el poder
a una mujer desde que nace me aseguro de
entenderla absolutamente todo lo que
exista para que ella sienta que lo va a
recuperar de nuevo ya estás lejos la
mejor estrategia de marketing y
publicidad de la historia mientras más
lejano sea el estereotipo que yo le
muestre una mujer mientras más
inalcanzable es la figura ideal femenina
que le estoy mostrando más me aseguro de
venderle todo lo que exista para que
ella crea que lo va a lograr
y hasta que no nos demos cuenta de que
somos como clases de esto esto no va a
cambiar esta es la base y la esencia de
la violencia de género y tenemos que
estar completas y absolutamente
conscientes de esto y tenemos que dejar
de ser cómplices de esto es una
responsabilidad social que lo hagamos de
cierta forma este mito por así decirlo
de calladita te ves más bonita empieza a
funcionar no nos damos cuenta y ya está
instalado y nos callamos y empezamos a
esconder empezamos a ocultar ocultamos
nuestras opiniones ocultamos nuestro
cuerpo ocultamos nuestro placer
ocultamos nuestro deseo nos convencen
de que tenemos que ser deseables en vez
de convencernos de que nuestro derecho
es desear nos convencen de esconder las
alegrías nos convencen de esconder las
disidencias de esconder la inseguridad
de esconder el sufrimiento pero la
pregunta importante acá es que estamos
permitiendo al esconder lo que nos pasa
lo que no se nombra no existe y si es
que no le podemos decir que no empezamos
a ponerle nombre a lo que nos pasa esto
va a seguir sucediendo
y es interesante darse cuenta que cuando
uno lleva estas cifras que por lo menos
algo que nuestro colectivo ha hecho
mucho porque tenemos a unas hermosas
académicas sociólogas doctoras en
investigación muy estudiosa en estas
temáticas que quisieran tener números y
llegamos a la conclusión de que por lo
menos en chile las niñas a los 15 años
dejan de levantarse de la toalla y
caminar en traje de baño porque les
importa mucho más lo que el resto del
mundo opine de ella y aquí es cuando
empezamos a cuestionarnos también esto
no es un tema de cuerpo saquémoslo
solamente de algo físico el que una niña
a los 15 años deje de sentirse libre
porque la opinión de otro es más
importante que su propia libertad esto
es un tema político y esto hay que
empezar a verlo así ya visibilizar lo en
chile las niñas entre 14 y 25 años pasan
tres horas al día pensando en cómo
mejorar su cuerpo
estos son 45 días al año
se dan cuenta de lo que esto es un mes y
medio al año perdido por estar pensando
en cómo puedo cumplir con un patrón que
todos los días se encargan de imponerme
se imaginan todo el tiempo y todos los
cambios que podrían existir si educamos
a nuestras niñas con una perspectiva
crítica para dejar de creer que eso es
lo que tienen que aspirar que su
propuesta de valor es mucho más grande
que solo cómo se ven
en chile el 86 por ciento de las mujeres
ha dejado de hacer algo que le gusta
porque no se siente segura de como usted
ve con su cuerpo
y dentro de estas cosas que estamos
dejando de hacer es levantar la mano
para ser escuchadas y dar nuestra
opinión esto es grave no podemos hablar
ni ni de textos de cristal ni de brecha
salarial ni de nada y aquí es donde
parte el problema si una niña no se
atreva a dar su opinión todo lo que
viene va a ser desigual y poco
equitativo y como lo va a ser así si lo
que vemos desde que somos niños es esto
es que somos un adorno una publicidad
que nos dice constantemente que somos un
adorno o que somos comible o posibles o
que de cierta forma estamos ahí para el
deseo de otro para que el otro haga lo
que nosotros hasta lo mismo nuestro
consentimiento da lo mismo este es el
mensaje que reciben todos los días este
es el mensaje con el que muchas de acá
hemos crecido desde que tenemos uso de
razón y cómo no vamos a sentirnos
insegura de nosotras mismas si los
medios de comunicación y la publicidad
construye en realidad y son uno de los
eslabones más importantes en la
construcción de identidad de los niños y
las niñas sobre todo hoy día que están
conectados y conectadas todos los días
entonces acá la pregunta importante que
hay que hacerse que me empecé a hacer es
qué pasa cuando abrimos los ojos qué
pasa cuando nos damos cuenta de que nos
tenemos que poner los anteojos violeta
de que si no los ponemos estos anteojos
violeta no vamos a entender lo que está
pasando si no empezamos a mirar el mundo
desde el feminismo esto
a cambiar nuestras niñas no van a tener
las mismas oportunidades si es que no
nos damos cuenta de que la sociedad
tiene que ser justa desde la infancia
cuando nos ponemos los anteojos violetas
nos damos cuenta de que no somos las
únicas que están viviendo lo que están
viviendo cuando nos ponemos los anteojos
violeta nos damos cuenta de que nuestro
sufrimiento no nos hace víctimas nos
hace maestras y que es una
responsabilidad social que como mujeres
empecemos a sentirnos orgullosas de eso
y la empecemos a decir a las niñas oye
levántate nos ha pasado
toma la mano somos muchas bemoles
tenemos que cambiar el mundo que lo
importante de esto también y qué es lo
que a mí me gustaría transmitir
la invitación hoy día principalmente es
que de acá todas y todos salgan con los
anteojos violeta puestos que empecemos a
ver el mundo desde ahí que entendamos
que la inseguridad vende y que tenemos
que segar dejar de seguir siendo
cómplices de esa industria de la
industria de la belleza de la industria
de la moda de la industria de las dietas
de la industria de la salud mental de
toda la industria que nos convence que
tenemos que ser distintas
para poder ser felices eso no es una
realidad porque por lo menos yo y muchas
de las que trabajamos juntas en la
rebelión del cuerpo estamos convencidas
de que no queremos más niñas calladitas
no queremos más niñas con miedo no
queremos más niñas perfectas
queremos niñas libres y queremos niñas
valientes y tenemos que dejar de educar
a las niñas para ser perfecta tenemos
que enseñarle a las niñas a que existe
el coraje y lo más importante de todo
tenemos que enseñarles a nuestras niñas
a que existe la sororidad y que la del
man la de al lado te va a dar la mano
cuando tú lo necesite porque está siendo
educada de la misma forma
y lo más importante de todo y la mitad
también el mensaje que más me gustaría
que vivías se llevarán a su casa es que
tenemos que darle espacio a la
autoestima ya la seguridad personal como
capital político como un poder del que
nos des apropiaron hace mucho tiempo
desde que nacemos pero que si nos
tomamos la mano todas juntas lo podemos
tener de vuelta y nos corresponde
tenerlo porque en una sociedad que lucra
con nuestra inseguridad gustarnos es la
mejor protesta de todas
[Aplausos]